judge number three NeNe Leakes your  question please a recent report shows  that in forty percent of American  families with children women are the  primary earners yet they continue to  earn less than men what does this say  about society well meaning it sounds  like a referring to an oft-quoted but  erroneous interpretation of a census  bureau report that claims female workers  are in 77 cents for every dollar made by  a man a wage disparity that mostly but  not completely disappears when you  contrast the relative earning power of  both genders in equivalent occupations  which is why PolitiFact gave president  obama rating of mostly false when he  repeated this error on national  television look here he is so to anyone  who says 77 cents on the dollar sounds  pretty close to equal I say your math is  bad thank you world peace out Thank You  Utah thank you sir all right next let's  have Alabama join us Alabama